the death of Jeffrey Epstein brings new
attention to his alleged co-conspirators
who could still face charges and number
one on that list is d'Alene Maxwell
who's accused of finding teenage girls
for Epstein and his friends including a
member of Britain's royal family that
particular claim has already been thrown
out of court but others remain Holly
Williams is in London outside Buckingham
Palace Holly
who is this guy Layne Maxwell good
morning well ghilane Maxwell grew up the
daughter of a wealthy British media
tycoon and studied at prestigious Oxford
University before becoming a close
associate of Jeffrey Epstein her current
whereabouts are unknown documents
unsealed on Friday contain allegations
that ghilane Maxwell played a quote
important role in Jeffrey Epstein sexual
abuse ring directing an underage girl to
have sex with Epstein and others Maxwell
strenuously denies those allegations
Jack's Carolla is an attorney who's
represented several alleged victims of
Jeffrey Epstein there are multiple
victims who claim that Jane Maxwell was
a personal participant in recruiting
them for Jeffrey Epstein and there are
allegations that Miss Maxwell was an
active participant in the sexual abuse
ghilane Maxwell has been described as
Epstein's ex-girlfriend and assistant
his best friend according to Epstein and
a socialite who helped connect him with
the wealthy and famous she's pictured
here attending Chelsea Clinton's wedding
it's an ocean based she even founded a
charitable environmental group but
Maxwell's also been described as a
Madame Epstein was reportedly able to
shield his alleged co-conspirators from
prosecution with a 2007 plea deal
Jack's Corolla says that included Elaine
Maxwell when a non-prosecution agreement
is entered into that grants immunity to
Jews Ain Maxwell and other named and
unnamed co-conspirators
for unspecified crimes that just doesn't
make any sense at all another famous
Brit caught up in this scandal is Prince
Andrew pictured here in 2001 with
Epstein's alleged victim Virginia
Jeffery and Maxwell the unsealed
documents repeat allegations that
Maxwell traffic Jeffrey to Prince Andrew
though that claim was previously
dismissed by a judge in the US and
struck from the record neither ghilane
Maxwell nor Prince Andrew have been
charged with any crime regarding Prince
Andrew Buckingham Palace said in a
statement quote any suggestion of
impropriety with underage minors is
categorically untrue but Prince Andrew
and his friendship with Jeffrey Epstein
are back on the front pages here in
Britain this morning scale yes Holly
Williams so many questions in this case
and I keep wondering how many other men
are shaking in their boots with the
release of the information that's coming
out and boys don't come out for
documents to come here we're talking
about that in the 8 o'clock hour we will
be lots of questions